bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
pour un nouveau numéro de c'est normand
nous sommes à saint pair sur mer dans la
manche
vous allez découvrir l' usine meuh cola
au delà de concurrencer les géants
américains c'est aussi le dernier
limonadiers de normandie jusqu'à 160
mille bouteilles de soda sorte de cette
unique ligne de production
le précieux breuvage le voici le col à
médine normandie de l'élaboration des
boissons top se traîne jusqu'à
l'emballage et l'expédition
le patron de cette petite cuisine et
multitâches enfin multitâche comme on
dit chez me collard c'est de la
production jusqu'à la création d'une
boisson le marketing le marketing l'eau
et puis la question bat ou la logistique
au delà du me collard le succès de cette
entreprise fondée en 2009
l'innovation aujourd'hui sébastien
bellétoile teste une nouvelle recette
sébastien c'est une étape j'imaginais
qui vous plaît parce que vous ne faites
pas tout le temps des nouvelles recettes
l'idée sera lui à sortir une boisson par
an donc oui ça me fait j'adore en fait
créé des nouveaux trucs quoi en plus de
la traditionnelle limonade à base de
citron plusieurs créations la roselyne
un soda à base de marc de raisin et la
paume nahd aromatisé au calvados mais
sans alcool c'est vraiment de travailler
sur une recette à partir de produits qui
ont une plus value
soit sociale soit environnementales
soient gustatives et là c'est le caramel
là c'est le caramel donc c'est sympa le
il ya un côté très traditionnels
normands aussi donc et on verra ça se
trouve
l'année prochaine on la lancera pas mais
au moins voilà on aura aussi un
ingrédient inhérents aux sodas les
sucres une trop forte consommation est
dangereuse pour la santé
sébastien bellétoile assure un
incorporait 8% de moins que la
concurrence mais un projet de loi
pourrait multiplier par trois la taxe
des produits secret ça risque de peser
de façon importante à savoir présenter
parce que 30 centimes sur une bouteille
de 8,5
nous on est déjà beaucoup moins de sucre
et on veut pas utiliser l'aspartame
parce que c'est un petit peu controversé
ils vont pas faire de distinction entre
le géant et puis la petite entreprise
artisanale qui essaye de bien faire quoi
pour l'heure cette année me colle à
enregistrer une croissance autour de 20%
mais ce jeune entrepreneur doit toujours
convaincre les bandes pour investir et
emprunter 30000 euros
j'ai remboursé après au mois de janvier
est bientôt là j'ai quand même montrer
que je tenais je vais tenir une
entreprise même si c'est un petit peu
particulier mais ces moments où j'ai
besoin d'eux et c'est un petit peu
frileux un soutien bancaire est
indispensable pour conquérir de nouveaux
marchés
les sodas sont distribués dans des
épiceries fines bistrot au restaurant
très bientôt ils seront vendues en
boulangerie 80% des produits meuh cola
sont vendus à travers la région en
normandie et pour les 20% restant à
migrer des points de vente à travers la
france à lyon à lille à toulouse ou
encore bien sûr à paris ben voilà et
puis comme quoi la vache normande n'a
pas fini de m'étonner de nous étonner
à travers la france et même l'europe
puisque bientôt ils vont aller en
belgique pour ses produits
allez à très vite pour un prochain c'est
normand sur france 3 merci lavage